so we're still in the month of nostalgia
weeds and we figures to talk about
another nostalgia Wien movie and I of
course would like to talk about the film
that coin a phrase we never thought
would be coined and that of course is
jelly side down let's talk about devil
jelly sat down as yappin off when we
watched it together was that the first
time you ever saw it yes that was that
was the first and last time isn't it
amazing
and I just I'm not convinced is that
supposed to be a dark house I'm almost
convinced like no this was a dark comedy
all along right look the biggest thing
that I me out of everyone was saying it
before we were saying it but it was
definitely like this is a good idea to
be trapped in an elevator and one of
them's becoming it's like one of those
logic yeah it's a very good idea it's
like five people in an elevator and then
you give certain quirks is like and the
lights go off and one of them dies and
the lights go on another one dies which
one's the killer yeah I mean it's just a
phenomenal idea for people that are
claustrophobic for people they're afraid
of you know who's you know the best
friend could be a killer or whatever
it's crazy and then you throw in the
devil which is just the one guy yeah
clearly doesn't belong here at all just
erases all logic anything and just makes
it totally insane so it's like it
would've been it would have been a great
thriller it would have been a phenomenal
brilliant like I would have found it
hilarious if jelly side-down guy was his
100% wrong and there was nothing
supernatural at all and at the end of
the fucking movie they just look at him
like when I'm done a great whiz there
was no devil what happened al Diablo and
you know or even talking about the devil
what just the killer like you know just
symbolically was like the devil he was
just everything that was evilly trying
to turn people against words I'm like at
the end it was actually like someone
that was like trying to make everyone
else think or me yeah again the guy that
was watching them was kind of like the
devil but symbolically wasn't actually
the devil you know he just like to see
people tear each other apart
whatever I don't know there's somebody's
work because there's no way to get to
twist cuz you just would've been more
like oh she's Satan yeah yes
you know the devil can do whatever you
want or she wants or whatever and it's
just like I mean it's one of those
things where it's like there's no
deduction to it there's no clues to it
or anything so it's not get it done the
opening credits were upside down
therefore everything is upside-down
therefore what doesn't make sense makes
sense hence this random chicks the devil
actually the same thing is I do count
like them so but in Christ actually I
see Jim is probably got a fucking thing
in the movie it's so simple just turn
everything upside down but I have
credits you know feels like yeah that
actually I was kind of definitely like
that really was the best thing in the
movie Oh
outside the Jason town I try to think
like the actors in this movie there are
definitely some very awkward actors in
this but not everyone is bad not like a
shamble on film where you know everyone
is just awful and it's how enjoyably
awful can they be I thought like the the
last two was down too I feel a lot of
people in the elevator are good I think
the one guy the guy that goes first the
obvious awkward jerk guy's the only one
that I'm like you're not working for me
you're quite but he got yeah he goes
quick so guys he could work but for the
most part I don't have a problem with
the acting in this probably because Sean
London directed yeah maybe bad but
that's saved it Friday I don't like
those ideas it's still that dialogue and
I wish one of them in that elevator
would have said toxins the toxins oh you
think I'm the devil No
um so yeah so yeah on the one hand is so
funny it is such an enjoyable bamboo
beebe on the other hand I'm so pissed
off because like somebody else now has
to come up with this idea of people
stuck on an elevator it's a thriller or
horror film but it's like you got to do
something different because this movie
did a lot of the good ideas but too many
bad ideas for it to you know not work so
some ways there has to be a good album
is so simple gets so convoluted
be like doing the movie phone booth only
in the last five minutes you find out
it's actually the fucking TARDIS yeah
okay well that would have been quick
sell in that twist would work yeah that
would really work though it would be
awesome but you've only got the TARDIS
then for five minutes yeah so for five
minutes like oh it's clothes Doctor Who
at the end I'm like what the hell like
cuz I'm just like okay if it really is
super nail I don't know it was one of
those where I was curious to see it
because I loved the idea and now is also
like but you know it shall want you know
what it could be one of those so bad
it's it's good movies what teaches yeah
no and I saw with my life and we were
just laughing our asses off at this
movie at just the weird dumb ideas
actually going on gotta be a comedy I am
facing it as much as like happening as a
comedy you know I made shit it's those
same weird ideas that just clearly don't
worry it's like he's caught in this idea
that's like you know it's kind of like
those Stephen King quirks that in his
books he can make work you know even
though a lot of them are repeated he
kind of makes them work we're in like
shallow on movies it's like he's pushing
them so hard and trying to make them so
quirky it's Daniel it's an examined
story where it takes something so
outlandish and puts it in the real world
but Neil Gaiman makes it work and
Shyamalan does not well Neil Gaiman I
think has a sense of humor about it were
shallow on you can't wait to take this
areas or not um you know it love me in
France well I mean that whole scene with
the gelly side down I mean it's just a
that's such a stupid idea be it's such a
ridiculous example to use I mean how is
anyone supposed to watch it be like woah
yeah yeah it's very creepy I I think
it's one of those things were kind of
like these again I don't know but it's
like it feels like one egotistical
writers as I had to see if they could
challenge themself can I make toast
scary can I make an elevator we did it
yeah didn't you have some wine about
Pokemon
yeah no when about I can't find this
quote but I know that I read this isn't
that Newsweek our phone proclaimed as a
nexus fielder all Lewis my
hey don't look for it but I can't find
this article but I know he said he can
take the story of Pokemon and make it
symbolic of the Holocaust he's that good
I know this line is out there and you
know it you know it kills me is you
absolutely could do that but I don't
think he could I'm like thinking right
now how would I do and I'm like all of a
sudden it was like a slot machine it was
like coaching but like here like I got a
thousand ideas I could do it he couldn't
but here's the thing again the jet goal
they get so occupy things you could
never stop to take a shot yes no you
should not make a poky members no
Schindler's List I up cries I'm already
thinking of like just these little pause
gravity shop oh this pokeball gonna save
to train you Pokemon Pokemon gotta save
them all it's really fun shit
somebody's gotta do this the pikas let's
just it's corn uhlet's can we just get a
John Williams like soundtrack like with
a sad violin Judy
I'm sorry this is this is what this
movie does you to keep pokemons to
Devils credit things like does it is so
joyfully bad it makes me giddy
it is a movie I was so excited to review
this movie because this movie like the
review like we really do throw in a
bunch of like various effects and angles
and stuff I even go on this elevator do
a lot of green screen wah audio
duplicating zooming up sunjammer as my
dad night like did that Cthulhu mask
yeah that was a nice image there are all
these like mechanics behind it to make
the only chair worked it and all day
yeah by the time we were all done
because I think it was we we painted it
in the paint like dried up and made it
so that visible yeah for all of this
thing it was reduced was brewed and then
citizen it still look pretty cool yeah
um I've um I've you so like the other
time yeah we had Santa Christ in there
and it was really fun for me because for
the first time I got to him probably
wasn't for the person but I really got
to play Santa Christ like out of
Caracalla the fun really grumpy and
surly I think the funniest deliveries of
Santa Christ lines ever don't make me
poke you 400 still your sweet red light
just on the elevator floor it comes
you're like a baby seal oh my god yeah
and what I like that everybody points
out is that we actually had a better
twist in our review within the movie tip
everyone's like a chai makes sense why
Santa Christ would be like that that
makes sense why the devil be that cares
I wasn't knowing I wasn't really saying
because the movie showed that a dead
person could come back there's a choice
there and then there's another twist
idea there's like three twists in our
review and they all kind of work it's
very liberating cuz Santa Christ is so
nice but I love it when the veneer like
the ball comes down any kind of like
give us our side
yeah like cuz everyone's like well what
I remember like so many fans were pissed
off like with the Sega Genesis bit we're
like oh I already got one and I'm just
like alright came all the way here
through a hurricane oh yeah here I feel
like Santa crazy wouldn't do that I'm
like
and Christ I'll tell you what he'll do
human which I don't like
oh yes human ever you every Santa Claus
on every mob Santa knows every once in a
while you just you snap a little even
Jesus was turning over tables the barber
yeah yeah yeah at the market when they
were trying to sell shit in his father's
house
I kissed yet you come into my house and
sell your bling um so yeah like I said
this movie I still recommend it it's
Jono and he's so enjoyable it's so
incomprehensible it just but I don't
know it's the kind of stupid that
doesn't make you mad it make likes it
makes me giddy
it makes me giddy with laugh like um one
of the happening yeah like it sang some
of like it I enjoy the happening as a
comedy hey Dad the devil Diablo Devils
right up here I say unlike happening
though devil again can have some good
ideas can have some good acting can have
some good angles and stuff they make
that elevator very claustrophobic and
stuff like that um I just thought how
bored is the devil cuz I'm just thinking
what an honestly do that a plan how does
time work in this does he do this for
everybody yeah there's gotta be a lot of
bad people out there tell you know you
know I gotta speed this up just the
theology behind this I just don't
understand well I think that's great
also having the devil in the elevator in
our version too so we could ask him
questions yeah like that but it's not
actually the devil that's why he's
defending it and that's that really is
one of our best reviews the more thing
about like I'm just looking back like
wow like everything yeah just kind of
work and the late rachel god rest her CS
uh but that wasn't right to leave a
mouseketool
very true she's not dead so buddy oh my
god you need sympathy then i'ma get
angry phone call from her yeah cuz she
clearly do that a very angry person no
she wouldn't we probably talked about
like The Silmarillion
she said some sort of talking gay people
don't know that about her and yeah I
never would have assumed about her but
like she was usually seeing Colbert she
and I were gonna like tow the town it's
like Tamra she sees no movies at all but
out of nowhere she is like a die-hard
like one of the most die-hard Tolkien
fan Kinane on the vaillar yeah like and
the Maya shit that most of you token
geeks probably don't know thanks really
it's um Darnell Quenya crap but like
nothing else geeky like nothing else
judicially geeky it is only Tolkien's
stuff that's like the one thing she's
like totally obsessed with um so yeah
she thinks talking about all that um so
yeah I think what else with this movie
no it's kind of like I know what you
talk let except just to say it's insane
yeah it's but it's so happily insane I
just I really enjoy watching this movie
it's not opens with a suicide I thought
that was a good metaphor yeah
punk like okay well there we go like
that's the message of movies gonna send
us I kind of feel bad one handed all
hope ye who enter here just jump again I
kind of feel bad when somebody has an
idea that's a good idea and a
challenging idea like if somebody was
just to say I can film a whole movie
inside a coffin a guy trying to get out
of a coffin and stuff it's like and some
people like can't be done and to me
anytime they hear that I'm like try it
see what happens can be done and it was
done it was done very well and they say
be done because just can't do yeah it's
one of those things were it's just
that's kind of infuriating cuz it's like
damn it this was this was good this was
a good idea but then you have to throw
in the devil for no damn reason and
think we should you wrote it as like a
treatment handed it to a student like
that's a great idea
send it off to someone else to rewrite
it probably should do that honestly
because at the very base level of it is
like they're not that bad
it's like Lucas great idea guy when it
comes to the execution that's where it's
all yeah like he actually really look at
this idea there do you think would be
like gatekeeper keymaster yeah they
either make the absolute worst thing
imaginable or like it actually turns out
something guys I think that would be
extraordinarily dangerous III not lead
what's the good I think it would turn
out something bad but uh yeah I know I
think it is one of those things where
it's like he probably yeah if only he
could be like a Disney Imagineer like
he'll come up with the idea and then
hand it over to somebody else and give
it to somebody with talent um so uh yeah
I guess I'm just getting to that you
know there is something just so like as
infuriating as that is that this
probably will not ever be made to a good
movie at least while we're alive cuz so
to me people are going to think of devil
uh and then laugh yeah and then that
will wreck the current movie um they
will still laugh and I think this movie
has brought a lot of Jono yeah we gave
us the gift of left and that is a
vocation yes he heals that wasn't his
intent maybe he'll heal the bad idea
that he is given us it's like it's sort
of destroyed it but also brought new
life to it in a strange way uh but in
Europe the kids love them the kids love
them in Europe I love that that's always
is he's like one Europe they love me I'm
like that's great you're making films
for an American audience what go to
Europe as if this is why there's gonna
be a war at sea oh did you shit here but
you know in China it's like don't go God
so um yeah I mean well like I said I
don't yes straight away I do look
forward to his eyes yeah I mean it
depends some visitors for so boring yeah
no no not visit not this at uh village
yeah the village was boring that visit
was a lot they're so insane that like
lady in the water was pretty fuckin ins
yeah that this new one coming out with
um Oh in Xavier Africa's name yelling
Xavier McAvoy uh looks so stupid yeah
jeez Meg me you know just looks so
stupid but so over-the-top I'm excited
like Shyamalan directing him you just
see this performance you're just like no
no this can't work but it's so not gonna
work in this beautiful way we like
mark Wolverton more like that sort of
craziness of like the happening and
stuff and not like after earth yeah
after that hurt yeah after week was more
low board some of the line in equities
and some of the ideas were we're
laughably bad but it's like yeah it was
more dull and slow and stuff like that
where something like devil or happening
for a movie with a character called
cypher Raige it lacked a little passion
the same so um yeah I think that's about
it if you haven't seen our review of it
definitely check that one out a lot of
people say it's like one of our best
ones and I really enjoy it too I think
it's really well done do it through
Santa Christ yes and it just has like
half our favorite characters in it um
and go see the movie the movie is really
fun in how ridiculous it is uh support
the good shitty Shaolin yes not the bad
shitty not the village not the after
Earth's but the happenings and the
Devils and uh yeah so go check out go
check both of them out even if you watch
our review go see the movie there
there's other stuff we couldn't get to
because obviously it's a review and it's
very very cool guy you know what make it
a theme night I'm thinking some devil's
food cake and some toast with jelly yeah
I throw it up in the air see what side
it lands and gonna eat it yeah off the
floor because that's what the devil
would want you to do everything Abhinav